hey theo this is uh greg from indiana so
uh me and my friends went out and caught
your show
dude you did phenomenal i actually just
went to call and tell you so i was at
work the other day and i just been kind
of in this like rut at work
it's not a bad job but i just really
want to get out of it stop
catching up on some of your podcasts and
um you said something like resonated
with me
you know you said nothing changes if
nothing changes
i thought about it and i went home and i
applied for a job i'm probably not
qualified for
but i was like i'll take a shot and the
next day i get a uh
call from him have the interview it goes
well she says she's gonna set me up
with uh in person interview never even
had it they
uh emailed me a few days later and i got
the job so now i'm going to be doing a
job that
i think i will appreciate more and enjoy
more and i'll be making double the money
that i'm making now
gang bro that's awesome man
that's really great uh congratulations
for trying something new yeah it's crazy
to sometimes think like
what can happen if we decide let i'm
gonna see what happens when i decide
that i
am qualified
what happens when i decide for myself
that i'm going to do something different
you know one thing you know jaco willing
was in here last week and one thing
that's really been
pressing with me that we discussed is
staying motivated
and i have been finding myself more
motivated even when i do not feel like
doing something to do it
that my brain doesn't dictate how my
brain does not get to
it my brain can feel a certain way but
it's not going to choose how i behave
all the time i just can't let it
do it anymore
gonna have setbacks i know
but if i'm feeling bad that doesn't mean
i'm doing bad that doesn't mean i
am bad that doesn't mean that i can't
still take some action
because yeah nothing changes and nothing
changes man
you know we'll sit around forever
wondering well what if i
you know what if i was a dog catcher
would i be the best what if i was a you
know
what if i worked on that you know at a
of avalanche
you know search you know searching for
avalanches and
predicting them or what is it called a
uh geologist
who would i you know would i be able to
do it would i
you don't know until you say yeah i'm
gonna you know what i'm gonna take
action nothing changes if nothing
changes man
and i'm not preaching at you i'm just uh
i just want to remind you because you
know i've spent a lot of time in my life
sitting around wanting things to change
um
and not being able to make them change
and not thinking i could
and i wish somebody had told me that
earlier sometimes
that in order for something to change
there needs to be change
um i'm proud of you man i'm happy for
you bro that's very exciting to hear
and that makes me feel good you know it
makes me feel good and thank you guys
for coming out in indianapolis
and i needed to hear that somebody came
out and had a good time with that show
because that one in the detroit one were
the two this week that i felt
i don't know
i just felt a little disconnected man uh
you know i think it just breaks my heart
sometimes that
that's something like as beautiful as
human beings are
that we're dying because of something as
as like dirty and preventable and
and sad as uh as drugs and as addiction
you know it just breaks my heart it just
breaks my damn heart bro
it breaks my heart
um
and just makes me want to work harder to
be part of the solution in the world
you know it makes me
it just makes me want to take care of
myself so that i can
just so i can be there for somebody else
if they need it not even know if i can
be but just so that there's a chance
that i can
you know it just makes me sad man
but knowing that there's people out
there who are making changes
and uh and who are coming out and
enjoying the show that's exactly what i
need to hear from me
and thank you for sharing that with me
brother you guys be good to yourselves
man gang
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one